hello my name is kazil parkov and my
project is titled the bioinformatics
approach to analyze the cut microbiota
in relation to liver cancer
this project has been depleted in
conjunction with buying biotech
where my mentor was dr raka blacksmith
[Music]
[Music]
my project
outline is a presentation about me
introduction the data sets the
methodology or methods use the results
conclusion and future suggestions
alongside the reference slides
about me i am gusel pargo finally
undergraduate completing their bachelor
of technology in bioinformatics
in amity university jaipur minecraft in
research in cancer and metagenomics
i am using my bioinformatics to unearth
novel information and this project is
centered around
the cut composition of muscular species
having liver cancer which is analyzed
using bioinformatics methods and
tools
the introduction primary liver cancer
and metastasis are amongst the fourth
leading causes
of death with relation to cancer
alongside being the seven most occurring
cancer worldwide
primary liver cancer is classified into
two broad categories
on the basis of histology and they are
hepatocellular carcinoma hcc and
intraoperative collagen carcinoma isis
hcc is the most frequent type of liver
cancer and originates in the hepatocytes
which are key to the immune system
activation
icc on the other hand is a lesser known
form and lesser frequent form
and occurs about 12 to 15 percent it
stems from cholangiocytes
which are basically the epithelial cells
lining the bile duct
here we can see
the pictures of a healthy liver and
an effector
following that
we have the human gut the human gut is
home to numerous kinds of microbes
including but not limited to bacteria
viruses and fungi and all of these
microorganisms
have a symbiotic relationship not only
livers the human body as a whole
we have seen empirical evidences uh
evidence with damaged levers being
associated with dysbiosis or imbalance
in the composition of gut microbiota and
there have been implications
of older gut microbiota infesting the
progression of these diseases
need for research the implication of
relationship between gut microbes and
liver
cancer
is solidified by the fact that the
microbial community in the gut have a
range of essential functions
like maintaining immune immune system
preventing colonization by pathogens
and also
synthesizing metabolites which
eventually end up passing through the
liver
and have an impact on the liver
the datasets which have been used are
not from the same project they are
from different projects
and they are the control data set
belongs to university of missouri
colombia
and the
cancer data set was submitted by dr tim
gratten
so the control data set is osmos
muscular species uh and contains the
normal
sequences of the gut microbiota whereas
the cancerous
uh samples contain the gut microbiota
sequences of
us muscular species affected by liver
cancer
the methodology used so here we use the
ada2 pipeline
and
the ddf2 pipeline is specifically
a pipeline which
corrects
illumina sequence dumblicon errors and
infer sequences exactly
and it also resolves the difference of
as
little as one might a nuclear type
so one difference from d882
and other
pipelines
is that
it performs denoising
and
follows it by merging the rates
this denoising
after merging reduces
the rate of inaccuracy and
makes tda2 unique amongst other buying
plans
so the start of the day two pipeline we
read in the first few files first q
files are basically faster files with
their quality scores
written
then we sort the forward and reverse so
forward and reverse reads basically mean
uh we submit two types of files which
are single end reads and paired in width
single end reads are
reads which have been separated
and split into forward sections and
reverse sections
and
then we have paired breeds which contain
both forward and reverse sleep
in one file itself
then we have quality inspection
filteration
which uses quality scores to trim
sequence the replication output which
gives us the output of unique sequences
along with abundances
uh denoising then merging rates then
removing of chimeras
assigning the taxonomy and the phylogeny
to the reeds construction of the phylo
sequence object which is also
can which can be also utilized in our
filtration of lower abundance rates and
then analysis for
diversity or any other further nulls
so the results are proportional
abundance class and control versus liver
cancer
gut microbiota with all the separate
classes shown here
and the
cancerous samples are here and the
control samples
are here
here we have the same graph but split
according to
the classes which is done by the facet
function in our
our
gdplot2 package and the output also uses
our phyllo sequence
to get the graph
so what we can see here is the classes
beat up
is that classes speed up proteobacteria
molecules the ferry bacteries gamma
proteobacteria and veduco microbial
are present in the cancerous samples and
belong tree dominantly to negative
ground strain
bacteria their abundances are especially
high
then following that we have
bacteria
vaseli
clostridia delta proteobacteria which
are present in equal composition in both
cancers
and control
uh samples
then we have actual bacteria
choreobacteria and a recipe leo
psychia which are positive drum strain
bacteria and present in higher bones
melano bacteria alpha proteobacteria and
negative
negative acutes are
negative bacteria present in equally
high abundance in the control dataset
we have fuso bacteria cardo bacteria and
thermal euphemia
which are a
mixture of positive
and negative
strains present
in
both in control data sets and are
present in a
lower
abundance now i have mentioned
here ground negative bacteria because
gram
negative bacteria
have an extra membrane
and are generally resistant to
anti-biotics and several classes of
antibiotics have been devi designed
to target gram negative bacteria
so now here we have chao one
and shannon one to
measure the alpha diversity
so cha one is an estimator which is
based on abundance
and basically it refers to the abundance
of individuals belonging to the classes
in the sample
so as we can see that the control
samples have a lower a higher to low
abundance
more mostly ranging on the higher side
whereas comparatively the cancerous
samples have a
lower
uh measure
this
from this we can infer that the
cancerous data
set
has lower number of singletons and
doubletons whereas the ciao
whereas the control datasets have a
higher number of singletons and double
things singletons or doubletons refer
those species which have
been recorded once or twice
in the samples
now shannon index is used to uh is used
to measure the diversity across
the data set and
here we can see that the control dataset
overall have higher diversity
although the cancerous
dataset or cancerous sample
also do have
a high diversity
now we have the ordination plot so we
can see that
the control data sets are divided into
three explicit
groups whereas the cancerous state of
cells
have a few outliers but are also divided
into three
specific or exclusive groups
so conclusions microbes
predominant in the cancerous samples are
gram-negative bacteria and we have also
seen a low abundance of gram positive
bacteria in the same
control samples on the other hand
contain a balanced amount of both
gram-positive and gram-negative bacteria
despite the lower or higher abundance
now char one shows a clear distinction
in the abundance both can control and
cancer samples
with cancer samples showing lower
abundance
and control samples showing the higher
abundance shannon index has shown that
both of these have a high range of
diversity
and the ordination plot shows that the
samples are divided into three clusters
each with more
outliers present in the cancerous
samples
suggestions
for future research includes in-depth
analysis of the species present in the
cancerous samples and how the absence of
several gram positive
bacteria
classes impacts the gut
and affects
affects liver cancer also exploration of
roles or several microbial classes in
the gut bacteria and what causes their
absence in the people suffering from
liver cancer
here are the references used in the
project and with this i conclude my
presentation